vamos a comparar dos cuartos y tres
cuartos pero primero pensemos un poco en
qué significan estas dos fracciones dos
cuartos significa que tenemos un entero
y lo dividimos en cuatro partes iguales
en cuatro secciones iguales y de esas
cuatro secciones iguales tomamos dos de
esas partes no se puede pensarlo como
una pizza si dividimos una pizza en
cuatro partes iguales y nos comemos dos
de esas partes ahora bien tres cuartos
significa que tenemos al mismo entero la
misma pizza también dividida en cuatro
pedazos iguales pero esta vez la
diferencia es que nos hemos comido tres
de esos cuatro pedazos así que tal vez
con esta descripción que sea más fácil
pensar cuál de estos dos es más grande
pero para hacerlo más claro vamos a
visualizarlo así que para estar muy
seguros de cuál
más grande voy a traer por acá a dos de
mis pizzas esta va a ser la primera de
ellas y también voy a traer a una más
que voy a poner acá abajo muy bien para
dos cuartos tenemos un entero tal vez
esta sea nuestra pizza y lo que voy a
hacer es dividir a este entero en cuatro
partes iguales así que vamos a hacerlo
voy a dividir a este entero en cuatro
partes iguales muy bien aquí las tenemos
y ahora lo que tenemos que hacer es
tomarnos dos pedazos de estos cuatro así
que aquí los voy a poner este va a ser
el primero muy bien y por aquí me voy a
tomar al segundo ya tengo dos de estos
cuatro pedazos así que esto representa
dos cuartos
de 4 y bueno ahora para fijarnos en tres
cuartos de nuevo vamos a dividir este
entero esta pizza en cuatro partes
iguales así que vamos a hacer lo vamos a
dividirlo en cuatro partes iguales pero
esta vez vamos a tomar tres pedazos de
estos cuatro así que aquí los tenemos
por aquí voy a tomar dos y aquí voy a
tomar tres de ellos
esto va a representar tres cuartos y
ahora ya podemos ver claramente que tres
cuartos es mayor o toma más espacio que
dos cuartos o podemos decir que dos
cuartos es menor que tres cuartos
recuerda este es el símbolo de menorca
porque el símbolo abre su parte más
grande al número mayor en este caso es
el segundo número entonces podemos decir
que todos cuartos es menor que tres
cuartos
cada una de estas cuartas partes es del
mismo tamaño así que dos de ellas va a
ser menor que tres de ellas muy bien
vamos a hacer otro ejercicio más así que
para eso voy a quitar este ejercicio con
el que empezamos y voy a traer por acá
otro ejercicio más pero esta vez
intentemos no dibujar las pizzas solo
vamos a intentar pensar en qué significa
cada una de estas fracciones y en cómo
compararlas bueno para cinco octavos
tenemos un entero y esta vez estará
dividido en ocho secciones iguales
para tres octavos tenemos también el
mismo entero y también estará dividido
en ocho secciones iguales pero aquí
tenemos cinco octavos tenemos cinco
pedazos de estas ocho secciones y en
tres octavos tenemos tres pedazos de
estas ocho secciones entonces los
pedazos son de la misma magnitud en
ambos casos son octavos pero aquí
tenemos cinco de ocho y aquí tres de
ocho y como los pedazos son del mismo
tamaño entonces cinco pedazos es mayor
que tres pedazos o cinco octavos es
mayor que tres octavos y observa que la
parte más abierta está señalando al
número mayor y en esta ocasión tenemos
al número más grande primero es por eso
que este es el símbolo de mayor que
cinco octavos es mayor que tres octavos